>> Tucker: CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATORS SAID THAT THEY
HAVE FOUND TROUBLING
IRREGULARITIES IN THE FBI'S
INVESTIGATION OF HILLARY CLINTON
AND HER EMAIL SERVER.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT IN THE
HILL, FBI AGENTS HEATHER
INVESTIGATION MICROMANAGED BY
HIGHER LEVEL OFFICIALS IN
CONTRAST TO ORDINARY PRACTICE.
YOU KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS.
THE INVESTIGATORS ALSO TOLD THE
HILL THEY FOUND EVIDENCE THE FBI
BEGAN DRAFTING AND EXONERATION
OF HILLARY CLINTON BEFORE IT HAD
EVEN GATHERED ALL THE RELEVANT
EVIDENCE WERE INTERVIEWED MORE
THAN A DOZEN KEY WITNESSES.
CHRIS IS A FORMER ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI AND HE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> GOOD EVENING, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: YOU'VE SEEN THIS
REPORT.
I DON'T THINK ANY AMERICAN WANTS
TO BELIEVE THE FBI IS ON THE
LEVEL AND SUBJECT TO POLITICAL
MANIPULATION, BUT THAT'S THE
WHAT'S YOUR CONCLUSION?
>> AS AN EXPERIENCED
INVESTIGATOR, IT DOESN'T TAKE A
CONGRESSIONAL INVESTIGATION TO
TELL ME THAT NOTHING ABOUT THAT
INVESTIGATION WAS RIGHT.
THOSE OF US THAT HAVE CONDUCTED
FEDERAL CRIMINAL INVESTIGATIONS
NO THAT YOU USE THE GRAND JURY,
YOU USE SEARCH WARRANTS, YOU
EVERYTHING INVESTIGATION RUNS
CONTRARY TO THE WAY A REAL
CREDIBLE, THOROUGH FBI
INVESTIGATION IS CONDUCTED.
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES THAT THIS
TIPPED YOU OFF THAT THIS WAS NOT
UNFOLDING AS IT OUGHT TO HAVE
BEEN.
>> FIRST AND FOREMOST, IN ANY
COMPLICATED FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION, THE BASIC TOOL OF
THE TRADE IS A GRAND JURY.
USE OF THE GRAND JURY TO OBTAIN
RECORDS.
YOU DON'T GO TO WITNESSES AND
SAY MOTHER, MAY I HAVE THAT
COMPUTER HARD DRIVE?
MAY I HAVE THOSE EMAILS?
UU SUBPOENAS AND PROCESS AND
GRAND JURY AND SEARCH WARRANTS
AND THAT SORT OF PROCESS.
THAT WAS THE TIP OFF FROM THE
BEGINNING.
SO MANY DEALS WERE MADE WITH
PEOPLE NOT KNOWING WHAT KIND OF
INFORMATION THEY HAD IN THE
DEALS BEING MADE SIMPLY BECAUSE
THEY LAWYERED UP AND DIDN'T WANT
TO TALK TO FBI AGENTS.
THAT'S WHEN YOU THROW THEM IN
FRONT OF A GRAND JURY.
>> Tucker: A LOT OF SUBJECTS,
MOST SUBJECTS I WOULD THINK
LAWYER UP AND NOBODY WANTS TO
TALK TO THE FBI, OF COURSE.
BUT THE FBI DOESN'T NORMALLY
CORPORATE THOUGHT TAX FORCE AND
I WAS RUNNING THE CRIMINAL
DIVISION, WE PLAY HARDBALL IN
THOSE INVESTIGATIONS.
YOU USE GRAND JURY PROCESS.
YOU DIDN'T JUST ASK FOR RECORDS
AND YOU DIDN'T GIVE THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAND OVER WHAT
THEY WANTED TO HAND OVER.
AND IF THEY DID LAWYER UP YOU
WENT TO THE TROUBLE OF THROWING
THEM IN FRONT OF THE GRAND JURY
TO PUT THEIR STATEMENT ON THE
RECORD, OR THEY CAN TAKE THE
FIFTH AND THEN YOU CAN MAKE A
DECISION AS TO WHETHER TO GRANT
THEM IMMUNITY AT THAT TIME.
BUT NONE OF THAT WAS DONE IN
THIS CASE.
>> Tucker: WHY?
>> THIS WAS LIKE DRIVING A CAR
WITH THE BRAKES ON.
>> Tucker: WHY WASN'T IT DONE
AND ALL OF MY FORMER COLLEAGUES,
PEOPLE WHO HAVE RETIRED FROM THE
FBI FROM EXECUTIVE LEVEL
POSITIONS ON DOWN TO THE STREET
LEVEL.
THE ONLY THING I CAN COME UP
WITH IS THAT DIRECTOR COMEY
PLACED THE INVESTIGATION IN THE
HANDS OF HIS INNER CIRCLE AND
THEY HAD THEIR OWN AGENDA,
OBVIOUSLY.
WE'VE SEEN THAT FROM SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT HAS SINCE COME
OUT, THE TEXT, ET CETERA.
>> Tucker: SO YOU THINK IT WAS
PEOPLE INSIDE THAT INNER CIRCLE
IN THE COMEY INNER CIRCLE THAT
HAD THEIR OWN PREDETERMINED
OPINIONS ABOUT TRUMP -- EXCUSE
ME, ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON AND
THE PRESIDENT, WHAT THEN WAS A
PRESIDENT-ELECT OR SOMEONE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU
ABOUT SOMETHING THAT I FOUND
REALLY STRIKING, TELL ME IF YOU
HAD THE SAME REACTION.
WE NOW HAVE DOCUMENTS THAT CAME
OUT IN A LAWSUIT THAT SHOW,
INTERNAL DOCUMENTS FROM THE FBI
THAT WHEN THE THEN
ATTORNEY GENERAL LORETTA LYNCH
HAD THE FAMOUS MEETING ON THE
TARMAC WITH BILL CLINTON, WHOSE
WIFE WAS BEING INVESTIGATED AT
THE TIME, THE FBI'S FIRST
REACTION WAS TO FIND OUT HOW THE
NEWS IT LEAKED.
DOES    THAT SEEMED LIKE A VERYW
DOES    THAT SEEMED LIKE A VERYI
DOES    THAT SEEMED LIKE A VERYD
REACTION TO ME.
>> THAT'S NOT THE FBI THAT I
KNOW AND AS I'VE SAID, MY FORMER
COLLEAGUES THAT I COMPARED NOTES
WITH ALL THE TIME, FORMER
DIRECTOR COMEY'S RATIONALE,
SHALL WE SAY FOR MAKING THIS
THAT SHE WAS NOT TO BE
PROSECUTED.
THAT WAS BASED ON THAT TARMAC
MEETING.
IF THAT WERE THE CASE, ALL HE
HAD TO DO IS HANG THE
INVESTIGATION TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE, LET
HER RECUSE HERSELF FROM MAKING
THAT DECISION, KNOCK IT DOWN TO
HER NUMBER TWO LEVEL PERSON AND
THEN IF THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN, THEN
MAYBE RAISE THE ISSUE PUBLICLY.
>> Tucker: IT REALLY